the Joe Rogan experience no I'd want to
kick his ass I want to [ __ ] him out to
kill him
I forgot the bet but what breaking news
liking some fighters I don't like this
what the fight off the suspense UFC 249
has been canceled all UFC events
postponed indefinitely due to kovat 19
Dana White says he's ready to promote
the event but things were taken out of
his control
much much more to come the government
stepped in on it you ain't due on the
ship that's interesting that's
interesting well that saves me a lot of
thinking [ __ ] damn I was 75% ready to go
you were gonna do it the only thing that
worried me is that if I contracted
something and then I came in contact
with other people so what I was gonna do
is do it if I definitely could get
tested and then I would have to know the
results before I come back it's [ __ ]
even then you don't know the testing was
a little dicey like it some people
saying there's a new type of test that
they're working on what is that they
don't have it officially done yet I
guess but when I was reading stuff about
the NBA it's said that they have
potential like instant tests right like
maybe a diabetic type test where you can
prick a finger get a little blood and
they can get something within 5 to 10
minutes I believe that also said it was
hypothetical and like if they can get
that done or get it
mass-produced or whatever it is yeah and
it works and it's accurate then they
will proceed but I'm so disappointed
looking out for human nature it's human
nature to you like when you look at the
stuff that Edward Snowden found out
about the NSA like of course they would
if they could they're going is gonna do
it they're gonna find a way it's human
nature it's just how we are man dude I
want to know who shut down UFC 249
because we know how adamant Dave more
waiting get that in there supposed to
happen
April 18th has been canceled Dana White
confirmed oh wow he was asked to stand
down by
Disney ESPN executives and he is doing
so damn thinking the power at Disney hey
Dana let's shut it down well I think
they made probably a risk assessment and
then they made a calculation of what the
negative aspects of going against
government regulations terms of like
state government would be I probably
can't do this they're saying it's not
worth it imagine being the president the
UFC [ __ ] all that imagine having all
these fights that you have to make and
having all this pressure on you and
you're also like a famous guy like
Dana's imagine being that guy [ __ ] that
job
Dana bleep president the UFC is second
only to president in the bank account
that's nice but you get used to that you
get used to the whole percent up you do
you do he's compensated well for it he's
compensated well making all the fights
he's he's making the main fight the main
events but the most important thing is
he's like a psychotic driving force for
the most exciting organization in the
world and I don't think the organization
gets where it is without Dana White
I think you have to have a crazy person
in the wheel I think you have to a
bulldog have a guy [ __ ] he's a real man
he doesn't give a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
he'll insult people go back with you
he's nuts
and then Disney went yeah you're wild
boy Disney went very cool your Island
yeah hope you didn't put money down
because we're shutting all that down
they're like what what are we doing here
well this is it and then they're
probably just the only thing that's up
and running like this this is up and
running they're ready to go right now
and I think I wish they would've let him
go cuz everyone have been just [ __ ]
fine yes 750 million dollars as long as
the right precautions are in place I
agree it would've been fine but the
thing is it's like you got to measure
good this if this was like just in any
other disease where we understood it
better I would be way more confident we
understand numbers though we do but we
don't understand Michael you
okay Michael you almost died yeah and
you know what Michael yos doing right
now he's fine right but he almost died
but he did it but he was in the hospital
for a week
yeah but he's fine okay okay now he's
fine I don't want people who are less
like robust then Michael yo to die so we
got to figure out like what the [ __ ]
this virus is how does it get treated
what's the most effective way
when can we shut and then then then it
makes sense that we're a little bit more
loose with our regulation 100% now when
now Michael yo decent shape he's in
decent shape compared to a UFC fighter
he's [ __ ] Adele you know I'm saying
like he's not in shape compared to Tony
firt he works out a lot he really does
again compared to Tony Ferguson right
yeah he's also not that old no and he's
you know college football player strong
loose term but yes I understand what you
see did he threw the ball he was
involved no rules Forrest anything you
could do like that in the forest its
Morris I give you an island that's what
I've been cool about this UFC thing if
it really did go to [ __ ] Island not
anymore
bro a couple of weeks yeah May they'll
be back up and running well the good
news is it's pure our response to this
cuz it happened in the moment the island
might still be in play because all the
other leagues are still figuring out
that like remote situation to face ocker
baseball basketball so they might well
if you could control an island if it's a
small island if you could control the
whole island test everybody why not how
much money is the UFC and be spending on
these private how much money are they
gonna be making with the reality show
about moving the UFC to the island
because I'm watching that [ __ ] [ __ ]
tiger king i watching Dana whites with
his crazy screaming and running around
trying to figure out it we're gonna put
all these [ __ ] fights trying to
figure out how to get a fight to an
island like coming up with an idea of an
island in international waters and who
owns the isle
that's one that's one episode this is
him on the phone call with yes mr. Trump
I understand mr. Trump Disney calling
him up yelling at him he's a wild man we
told you have to throw those 47 fights I
think they're gonna relax a little I
think people are gonna hopefully realize
that the worst is behind us I think
maybe I'm a hope and I'm hoping they
just obviously I'm hoping the current
treatment is the one that works but to
if that's not the one that works maybe
they find something just as good I think
we got a lot accomplished how about the
fact that it happens why we're on the
podcast that was pretty crazy wouldn't
cover too much of it
listen man I was hesitant my thoughts no
you were I was like hmm I really want to
go like it was leaning towards going
that my god I don't want to hear it from
people that don't think it's a good idea
I'm not interested in putting myself at
risk but my real concern was how do I
know if I can tract it and then I bring
it back how am I gonna know and I had to
be honest to myself and like I really
wouldn't know so the only way I would be
able to do it is to do it and then be in
quarantine until I get tested that ain't
worth it oh my god Jesus Christ why I
want to find out man
[Applause]